alors maintenant d'autres questions un
peu plus difficile or pascal qu'est ce
qu'un capitaliste un habitant la
capitale oui et un centenaire une amie
qui peut 700 francs oui ce trade une
question très difficile
pourquoi cook dont la tête des sardines
avant de les mettre dans une boîte
tournait pas qu'elle doive nuit très
bien et où élèves sont les huîtres dans
des parkings wii passe dans l'histoire
de france jérôme qui a repoussé les
arabes à poitiers ils ont repoussé tout
seul oui et office signé le traité de
versailles
condamne leur sens très bien mais
j'allais oublier vincent vincent dix
mois le défaut de celui qui est rare
c'est l'art à la 20e' celle très bien et
l'impératif du verbe se taire
chut